Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Tilius crouched at his side, holding out his petition. Impatiently, Caesar waved it away, and then, quite unexpectedly, Tilius grabbed hold of the dictator's purple-lined toga and yanked it down. Utter bewilderment flashed across Julius Caesar's face. This is violence, he shouted. Something darted towards his neck.
感谢您收听《历史的余烬》。想要收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告广播、抢先体验系列节目并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区吗？请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。提利乌斯（Tilius）躬身走到他身旁，双手递上请愿书。凯撒不耐烦地挥手将它推开，接着，出乎所有人意料，提利乌斯一把抓住这位独裁者饰有紫色边缘的托加长袍，猛地向下拽去。尤利乌斯·凯撒的脸上一闪而过彻底的迷茫。这是暴力！他大喊道。有什么东西朝他的脖子猛刺过来。
A blinding pain, a smear of red. Half turning, he saw blood dripping from a dagger. There were people crowding around him now. Familiar faces, friends, men he had trusted for years. They all held knives. Their eyes were hard. More steel flashed towards him. His head was whirling. He raised his hands to shield himself and saw the blood running down his arms. Now he was twisting,
一阵刺痛，一片血红。他半转过身，看到鲜血正从一把匕首上滴落。此刻，周围挤满了人。一张张熟悉的脸孔，都是朋友，是他信任多年的同仁。他们手里都握着匕首。他们的眼神冷酷无情。更多的寒光朝他刺来。他的头脑一片混乱。他抬起双手抵挡，看到鲜血顺着双臂淌下。此刻他正在扭转身体，
cornered, a wild beast at bay. He could hear somebody bellowing, a monstrous roar of fear and panic, and he recognised his own voice. He was trapped. He couldn't get up. There was blood everywhere. The faces were coming closer. The knives rose and fell. And then, to his relief, he saw Brutus. Good old Brutus. But Brutus's eyes were hollow, and in his hand was another knife. Et tu, Brute? Caesar said, disbelieving. You too, my boy. So, Tom, that's one of the most famous scenes in all history. The assassination of Julius Caesar on the Ides of March in 44 BC at the Theatre of Pompey in Rome. It's probably, isn't it, one of the, I hate to use the word iconic because it's such a cliched and overused
陷入绝境，犹如一头困兽。他听到有人在怒吼，那是恐惧与惊慌发出的可怕咆哮，而他认出了那是他自己的声音。他被困住了。他动弹不得。到处都是血。那些面孔越来越近。匕首起落不断。接着，令他感到宽慰的是，他看到了布鲁图斯。好兄弟布鲁图斯。但布鲁图斯的眼神空洞，手里还握着另一把匕首。“还有你吗，布鲁图斯？”凯撒难以置信地说道。“你也有份，我的孩子。”所以，汤姆，这是整个历史上最著名的场景之一。公元前44年3月15日（即伊德斯节），尤利乌斯·凯撒在罗马的庞培剧场遭到暗杀。这大概是……我讨厌用“标志性”（iconic）这个词，因为它太陈词滥调、太被滥用了，
word but it is an iconic moment it's been repeated in painting after painting play after play films and even children's books tom like that one that i was just reading so what did that come from dominic so that came from um adventures in time cleopatra queen of the nile by an author not unfamiliar to listeners to this podcast maybe it's a measure of just how iconic the murder of Caesar is that actually between us, we've written up four accounts of the murder of Caesar. So you did it in your book, your children's book. I've done it twice in two books. I've written Rubicon and Dynasty, and I've translated Suetonius on whose account much of your account was based. And actually, I sent it to you, didn't I?
但这确实是一个标志性的时刻，它在无数的画作、戏剧、电影甚至儿童读物中被一遍又一遍地重现，汤姆，就像我刚刚读的那本一样。那么，这个出处是哪里呢，多米尼克？噢，那是来自……《时空历险记：尼罗河女王克利奥帕特拉》，作者对本播客的听众来说并不陌生。也许，凯撒之死之所以如此具有标志性，正是因为我们俩其实已经写过四篇关于凯撒遇刺的记述了。你在你的书中写过，也就是你的儿童读物。我已经在两本书里写过两次了。我写过《卢比孔河》和《王朝》，我还翻译了苏埃托尼乌斯的作品，你的很多记述就是以他的记载为基础的。事实上，我把它发给你了，对吧？
And suggested that you read it. And you scored. And I ignored it. Not going for Suetonius. I'm going for myself. Yes, exactly. It is absolutely one of the most, as you say, celebrated scenes in the whole of history. And it's celebrated partly because it has been said, I think absolutely accurately, that it is probably, we know more about the events of the Ides of
还建议你读一读。结果你……我给无视了。我没参考苏埃托尼乌斯。我走的是自己的路。没错，确实如此。正如你所说，这绝对是整个历史上最著名的场景之一。它之所以备受瞩目，部分原因正如人们所说——我认为完全准确——那就是，关于3月15日那天所发生的事情，我们所了解的细节，
March than we do about any other day in the whole of ancient history. So we can talk about it in some detail. But it's also because it polarises all kinds of political issues that reverberate throughout Roman history. In some way, it's the kind of the great bottleneck in Roman history between the age of when Rome is a republic and when it becomes an autocracy. But also for future generations, for future centuries. justified or whether it was a crime is something that people have debated and that has animated revolutionaries right the way into the present. Oh, you think about the death of Mara or the assassination of any political leader. Couldn't you say, Tom, this is the most emblematic, the most resonant political act in all history? Is that too big a claim?
可能比整个古代历史上任何其他一天的都要多。所以我们可以非常详细地讨论它。但这也是因为它两极化了各种各样的政治议题，而这些议题在整个罗马历史中回响不绝。从某种意义上说，它是罗马历史上的一个巨大瓶颈，连接着罗马作为共和国的时代与它成为独裁政权的时代。而且，对于后世和未来的几个世纪来说，……这场刺杀究竟是正义之举还是一场罪行，一直是人们争论不休的话题，并一直激励着革命者直至今天。哦，你想想马拉之死或任何一位政治领袖的遇刺。汤姆，难道你不觉得这是整个历史中最具象征意义、最耐人寻味的政治事件吗？这个说法是不是太夸张了？
It's been retold so many times, and perhaps in the English-speaking world, because it's the theme of Shakespeare's play. And Shakespeare's play is so exquisitely balanced between whether Brutus and Cassius, the two principal conspirators, particularly Brutus, whether he's justified in what he does, or whether he has committed a terrible crime. I think you're right. I think that the issues are perennial and irresolvable ultimately. But it's also, of course, a key event in the context of Roman history, because effectively, it marks the end of a very, very distinctive period in Roman history, which is that when Rome is, you know, for centuries has been a republic.
它被重新讲述了无数次，也许在英语世界里，是因为它是莎士比亚戏剧的主题。而莎士比亚的戏剧在这一点上平衡得极其精妙：布鲁图斯和卡修斯这两个主要的阴谋家——尤其是布鲁图斯——他们的所作所为究竟是正义的，还是犯下了滔天大罪？我觉得你说得对。我认为这些议题是永恒的，最终也是无法彻底解决的。但当然，在罗马历史的语境下，它也是一个关键事件，因为从实质上讲，它标志着罗马历史上一个非常非常独特的时期的结束，也就是罗马作为一个——你知道的——几个世纪以来一直是共和国的时期。
And the conspirators murder Caesar because they think that he has made himself supreme within the context of the republic. And so they are worried that he's going to destroy it. And they kill him to try and rescue the Republic. But the great tragedy, and again, this is why the event is so resonant, the great tragedy of their attempt is that they end up destroying what they've been attempting to save. Yeah. We did a couple of episodes this time last year about Caesar's decision to cross the Rubicon and his war with Pompey, with Pompey the Great, which sort of sets the stage for all that. But I know a lot of people won't have heard that. So for those people who are new to this, Julius Caesar was born in 100 BC, isn't he? And he's from a very rich and noble family. And just why is it that Caesar, more than anybody else, comes to personify in the minds of
阴谋家们谋杀凯撒，是因为他们认为凯撒在共和国的框架内让自己凌驾于众人之上。因此他们担心他会毁掉共和国。他们杀他是为了拯救共和国。然而，最大的悲剧——这也是为什么这一事件如此耐人寻味——他们企图拯救的东西，最终却被他们亲手毁灭了。是的。就在去年这个时候，我们做过几期节目，讲的是凯撒决定跨过卢比孔河以及他与庞培（即伟大庞培）的战争，这为这一切做好了铺垫。但我知道很多人并没有听过那一期。所以，对于新听众来说，尤利乌斯·凯撒生于公元前100年，对吧？他出身于一个非常富有且高贵的家族。那么，为什么凯撒比任何人都更能成为刺客心中共和国威胁的化身呢？
his assassins, the threat to the Republic? Well, the key to the success of the Republic over the course of its centuries of existence is that it had been absolutely brilliant in providing scope for its most ambitious men to do great things on behalf of the city, while at the same time channeling and framing them so that the ambitions of these men didn't come to put the whole of the Republic in its shadow. For the Romans, the word king was an incredibly dirty word. The Republic, rather like the American Republic, had been founded with the expulsion of a monarchy. And so the idea that a single man could rise to power within the Republic was every Roman's worst nightmare. And so the entire structures of government had been fashioned to ensure that that didn't happen. So the powers of the king had been given to two officials called consuls. Each consul would have power for a single year. There were lesser magistrates. So below the consuls, there were magistrates called praetors who were the kind of the deputies and so on all the way down.
好吧，共和国在其数百年的存在中能够取得成功的关键在于，它在为最有野心的男士们提供大展身手、为城市建功立业的空间方面表现得极其出色，同时又能对他们进行引导和约束，使这些人的野心不至于让整个共和国笼罩在他们的阴影之下。对罗马人来说，“国王”这个词是个极其不光彩的词。共和国的建立，很像美利坚共和国，伴随着君主制的驱逐。因此，共和国境内竟然能出现一个独裁专权的人，这是每个罗马人挥之不去的噩梦。于是，整个政府结构的设计就是为了确保这种情况不会发生。因此，国王的权力被一分为二，交给了被称为执政官的两位官员。每位执政官掌权仅限一年。还有较低级别的行政官。在执政官之下，有被称为裁判官的行政官，他们相当于副职，依此类推，层层递进。
And the idea was that as you know, if you if you had the wealth, if you had the background, if you had the prestige, if you had the popularity with the voters, you would ascend up the greasy pole. You would go up this chain of magistrates and ultimately become a consul and hopefully win glory for Rome by conquering Gauls or whatever. But you would then accept the fact that you'd had your time in the sun and it was time to stand down and let someone else have a go. And this was the way that the Republic had functioned. And it made it incredibly successful because the ambitions of these men were what enabled them to expand through Italy, across the Mediterranean, and become the greatest power in the Western world. What happens in the first century BC, when Caesar is born, is that the Republic has become so powerful, so huge, that institutions and frameworks of government that had worked very well when Rome was a city-state in Italy, is starting to come under pressure and strain. And one of the things that becomes evident is that the old days of allowing someone to have a command for a single
其构想是，如果你拥有财富、背景、威望以及选民的支持，你就会沿着这条仕途不断高升。你会通过这一系列的行政官职位一路向上，最终成为执政官，并有望通过征服高卢等地为罗马赢得荣耀。但随后你必须接受这样一个事实：你风光的时间已经结束了，现在是时候卸任，让其他人来试试了。这就是共和国曾经运作的方式。这让它取得了难以置信的成功，因为正是这些人的野心，使他们得以向意大利各地扩张，跨越地中海，成为西方世界最强大的力量。公元前1世纪凯撒出生时发生的情况是，共和国已经变得如此强大、如此庞大，以至于那些在罗马还是意大利的一个城邦时运转良好的制度和政府框架，开始承受压力和考验。其中显现出来的一个问题是，过去那种允许某人担任指挥官仅一年的旧制度，
year is inadequate for the scale and sweep of Rome's empire. And that in turn is threatening for the Republic, because it means that one man might be given a command that lasts longer than a year. And that, of course, enables him then to the idea is, is that you can only win certain you're 40, you can become a consul. Pompey has ignored this. He has been after commands right from his teenage years. And he has spent years in the East annexing wealthy Greek kingdoms, bringing them into the Republic. And when he comes back to Rome,
已经无法满足罗马帝国庞大的规模和广阔的疆域。而这反过来又对共和国构成了威胁，因为这意味着可能会赋予某人长达一年以上的指挥权。而这当然会让他能够……按照设想，你只有在40岁时才能成为执政官。庞培却无视了这一点。他从十几岁起就一直在追求兵权。他在东方度过了多年时间，兼并了富裕的希腊王国，将其纳入共和国的版图。当他回到罗马时，
he is kind of trailing. He's got kings in his train. He's got great chests of treasure, all kinds of things like that. So he's too rich, really, for the system. He's too rich. But Pompey is a figure of menacing power in the context of the Republic, but he's an inherently conservative figure. He wants to be acknowledged as the princeps, the chief man in the state. But he doesn't want to overthrow the Republic or anything like that.
他的随从中有着大批随行的国王。他的队伍里带着沉甸甸的财宝箱，以及各种各样的战利品。所以，对这个体制而言，他实在是太富有了。他实在是太富有了。然而在共和国的语境下，庞培不仅是一个构成威胁的强权人物，他本质上也是一个保守派。他希望被公认为“元首”（princeps），即国家的第一公民。但他并不想推翻共和国或做诸如此类的事。
He's far, far too conventional. Right. And so he enters into alliance with two other very heavyweight figures, one of them Crassus, incredibly wealthy, also from the kind of same background as Pompey. He's emerged from a civil war, and he ends up dead fighting the Parthians out in the east. Yeah.
他实在是太墨守成规了。没错。于是他与另外两位重量级人物结成了同盟，其中一位是克拉苏，富可敌国，背景也和庞培差不多。他是从内战中崛起的，最终在东方的远征中与帕提亚人作战时战死。是的。
His head is used as a prop in a drama and all kinds of things like that. They have a hanging around the court, don't they? Yeah. Parthian court. But the third figure in what is known as a triumvirate, becomes known as the triumvirate, the rule by three men, is this figure, Julius Caesar, who is very, very ambitious. His family, although, as you said, patrician, in fact,
他的头颅被当作戏剧中的道具等等。他们把头颅挂在宫廷里，对吧？是的，帕提亚宫廷。但是，被称为三头同盟（即三人执政）的三巨头中的第三个人，就是这个尤利乌斯·凯撒，他有着非常非常强烈的野心。他的家族虽然正如你所说属于贵族，事实上，
claims its descent all the way back to the goddess Venus, has not been, they haven't been big players through the course of Roman history. And so Caesar is very, very anxious that he should live up to the glamour and the glory of his, you know, his divine descent. And he recognises that the only way really to become a great man in the context of the Republic now is not to play by the rules, but to do what Pompey has done and to grab a command. And his command is he gets first five years and then ultimately 10 years in Gaul, what's now France. And he conquers it. And with this, he becomes as rich as Pompey has done. And he also has a large number
声称自己的血统可以一直追溯到女神维纳斯，但在罗马历史的进程中，他们一直算不上什么大角色。因此，凯撒极其渴望不负他那神圣血统所带来的光环与荣耀。他认识到，在如今共和国的语境下，要想成为一个伟大人物，唯一的途径不是按规矩办事，而是效仿庞培，夺取兵权。而他的兵权是——他先是得到了五年，最终得到了十年在当时被称为高卢（即现在的法国）的统治权。他征服了高卢。凭借这一点，他变得和庞培一样富有。同时，他的身后也拥有了大量
of very battle-hardened and devoted legions at his back and his enemies in Rome try and back him into a corner they try and strip him of his command Caesar is you know he has this excruciating dilemma does he lay down his command risk prosecution but not break the law or does he lay down his command, risk prosecution, but not break the law? Or does he break the law and cross this tiny river that marks the limit of his Gallic provinces, the Rubicon, and effectively declare civil war? And that is what he chooses to do. And so that's what we described in the episodes we did on the Rubicon. Pompey, despite having been regarded with great suspicion by the kind of traditional conservative senatorial elites, he takes the command of the kind of the senatorial cause against Caesar. He withdraws from Italy to Greece because he doesn't have the soldiers that Caesar has for an immediate confrontation in Italy.
经历过百战淬炼且忠心耿耿的军团。他在罗马的政敌们试图将他逼入绝境，企图剥夺他的兵权。凯撒陷入了极度的痛苦抉择之中：他是该卸任兵权、冒着被起诉的风险但遵纪守法呢，还是该卸任兵权、冒着被起诉的风险但遵纪守法？或者，他是否应该触犯法律，跨越那条标志着其高卢行省边界的小河——卢比孔河，从而实质性地宣布爆发内战？而这就是他最终选择的道路。这正是我们在关于卢比孔河的节目中所描述的内容。庞培尽管一直被传统保守的元老院精英们视为充满戒备的对象，但他还是挑起了反对凯撒的元老院阵营的统帅权。他从意大利撤退到希腊，因为他没有像凯撒那样随时能在意大利正面抗衡的士兵。
Caesar follows him, defeats him at a battle at a place called Pharsalus. Pompey flees, ends up murdered in Egypt. And again, we've talked about that in the episodes that we've done on Cleopatra. Caesar then spends his time pursuing the, basically he has two groups of enemies. He has Pompeians, so Pompey has sons, they want to continue the fight. Sextus Pompey is the most famous of them, isn't he? Yes, he's a kind of perennial survivor in the fight. But he also has these traditionalists, these people who see Caesar as a menace, an aberration, a would-be king. And so they have deep ideological reasons for continuing to fight him. The key opponent, oddly, is someone who doesn't really have a great command. He doesn't have a great track record of
凯撒尾随追击，在一个叫做法萨卢斯的战役中击败了他。庞培仓皇逃窜，最终在埃及被谋杀。同样，我们在关于克里奥帕特拉的节目中也探讨过这一点。随后，凯撒把时间花在追捕……基本上他有两类敌人。他有庞培派，也就是庞培的儿子们，他们想要将战斗继续下去。小庞培是其中最著名的一个，对吧？是的，他是这场斗争中历久弥坚的幸存者。但他还有那些传统派，也就是将凯撒视为威胁、反常现象以及潜在国王的人。因此，他们拥有深刻的意识形态理由来继续与他作战。奇怪的是，他最主要的对手并不是一个拥有赫赫兵权的人。他没有显赫的
magistracies. He's not a major military figure, but he is a person who has made himself absolutely the embodiment of everything that conservatives and traditionalists in the Republic admire about Rome and about their system of government. And this is a guy called Cato. And Cato has always been Caesar's great enemy. And they come to be seen as the two greatest figures in the Republic. So there's a follower of Caesar who in due course becomes a historian called Sallust. And he writes about these two men, Caesar and Cato, that during his own lifetime, he says, there appeared two men remarkable for their qualities, very different though they were in character. And it's these differences in character that kind of amplifies the sense that Romans have of the significance of both. So they both embody a set of values, don't they?
仕途履历。他并非主要的军事人物，但他却让自己成为了共和国里的保守派和传统派对罗马及其政府体制所崇拜的一切事物的绝对化身。这个人名叫加图（Cato）。加图一直是凯撒最大的死敌。他们后来被视为共和国最伟大的两个人。凯撒的一位追随者后来成了一名历史学家，名叫萨卢斯特（Sallust）。他在书中写到这两个人——凯撒和加图时说，在当代，曾出现过两位品质非凡的人物，尽管他们的性格截然不同。正是性格上的这些差异，放大了罗马人对他们二人的重要性的认知。因此，他们两人都体现了一套价值观，对吧？
Caesar is the showman playing to the crowds and Cato is the incarnation of Republican sort of austerity. Is that right? Yeah. So you might say, I mean, it's an analogy that we've touched on before, and this is being very unfair, I think, both to Caesar and to Cato, but you might compare them to the difference between Trump and John McCain for American listeners. Caesar is a flamboyant populist. He is prepared to trample down on the conventions and the norms of the Republic and do so knowing that it will appeal to a substantial base.
凯撒是那个迎合大众的表演大师，而加图则是共和政体那种苦行精神的化身。是这样吗？是的。所以你可以说——这是一个我们以前曾触及过的比分类比，而且这对凯撒和加图来说可能都有失公允——如果你向美国听众解释，你可以把他们比作特朗普与约翰·麦凯恩之间的区别。凯撒是一个张扬的民粹主义者。他准备践踏共和国的习俗和规范，并且深知这样做能够迎合庞大的底层基础。
So the vulgarity and the offensiveness is part of the point. He's not vulgar. I mean, he's not vulgar. He's not vulgar and he's not offensive. He's a very, very sophisticated man, but he is flamboyant and he is unafraid
所以，粗俗与冒犯正是他手段的一部分。但他并不粗俗。我是说，他并不粗俗。他既不粗俗，也不冒犯人。他是一个极其老练、极其成熟的人，但他个性张扬，而且无所畏惧，
to cut a dash. Cato is the absolute opposite. He is kind of hewn out of granite. When he meets foreign dignitaries, he does so on the toilet. He is making a point about the fact that he is contemptuous of anything that is flash, anything that might be faintly redolent of monarchy. And he detests Caesar and Caesar detests him. And in the build-up to the Rubicon, it is basically Cato's obduracy that prevents a compromise from being struck. You know, Cato is as complicit in the outbreak of civil war as Caesar has been. And so in the spring of 46, so this is two, three years after the beginning of the Civil War, Caesar comes to Africa where one of his great enemies, a guy called Metellus Scipio, who is basically a kind of vicious non-entity, chiefly famous for his, he has a particular talent for staging pornographic floor shows, but that's basically it. He doesn't sound like a non-entity at all, Tom. I think you're being very harsh.
敢于独树一帜。加图则完全相反。他就像是用花岗岩雕刻出来的一样。当他会见外国政要时，竟然坐在马桶上接见。他借此表明，他对任何浮华、任何可能带有轻微君主制色彩的东西都充满鄙视。他厌恶凯撒，而凯撒也厌恶他。在卢比孔河事件的发酵过程中，基本上正是加图的顽固不化，才阻碍了妥协方案的达成。你知道的，加图对内战爆发负有和凯撒同等程度的责任。因此，在公元前46年的春天——也就是内战爆发两三年后——凯撒来到了非洲，当时他的一个主要死敌，一个名叫梅特鲁斯·西皮奥（Metellus Scipio）的人正在那里。此人基本上是个恶毒的无名小卒，主要以……他有一种特殊的才能，擅长上演色情地板秀，但基本上也就这些了。听起来一点也不像个无名小卒啊，汤姆。我觉得你太严厉了。
In the field of pornographic floor shows, he's a leading figure. He's the big man. But when it comes to military competency, he's hopeless. And he's leading the anti-Caesarean forces in Africa, and he gets defeated at a place called Thapsus. Now, Cato, he is in command of a town that is just down the coast from Thapsus, a place called Utica.
在色情地板秀领域，他绝对是个领军人物。他是巨擘。但若论及军事才能，他简直一无是处。他当时正统领非洲的反凯撒势力，结果在塔普苏斯（Thapsus）这个地方被击败了。而加图，他当时正统帅着一座紧邻塔普苏斯海岸的小镇，一个叫乌蒂卡（Utica）的地方。
Yeah. And he's brought the news that Caesar has won at the Battle of Thapsus, that yet again, he has triumphed. And he knows that, you know, there's no way of carrying on the fight. So what does he do? He has the choice of submitting to Caesar and he knows that Caesar will pardon him.
是的。当他接到消息说凯撒在塔普苏斯战役中获胜、再次大获全胜时。他深知，（抵抗）已经毫无胜算。那么他会怎么做？他面临着向凯撒投降的选择，而且他深知凯撒会赦免他。
Yeah. And this to us is something that's very attractive about Caesar. Yeah, his magnanimity. He's an extraordinary thing, isn't it? He's a very generous man to his former opponents. So he's both formidable, but he's also forgiving. Clementia, they call it, so clemency. But for Cato and for people like him, this is actually incredibly offensive because this is the quality that a master might show his slaves. It's the quality that a king might show his subjects. And so to be forgiven by your peer is incredibly humiliating. And for Cato to be forgiven by Caesar would be, you know, a horror beyond compare. And so he decides that he's going to kill himself. And he he invites his friends to to dinner.
是的，这对我们来说是凯撒极具吸引力的一面。是的，他的宽宏大量。这真是一件不可思议的事，不是吗？他对前政敌非常慷慨。所以他既令人敬畏，又十分宽容。他们称之为“宽容”（Clementia），也就是仁慈。但对于加图和像他这样的人来说，这其实是极具侮辱性的，因为这是主人对待奴隶时才会表现出的品质。这是国王对待臣民时才会施予的恩惠。因此，被同等级别的对手所原谅，是极其屈辱的。对于加图来说，接受凯撒的宽恕将是一场无可比拟的噩梦。于是，他决定自杀。他邀请朋友们共进晚餐，
They have a discussion on kind of philosophical themes. Then he goes upstairs and he stabs himself and he doesn't do it very competently. He's found his friends try and stitch up his, you know, his stomach. He's left alone. He pulls open the stitching oh tom pulls out his guts and dies kind of very horribly yeah but very nobly and caesar arrives in utica he's shown cato's corpse um and he kind of stands over the body and says that just as you envied me the chance of sparing you, Cato, so I envy you this death. And there is this sense that although Caesar has defeated all his other enemies, Cato in a sense has defeated him.
大家探讨了一番哲学主题。随后他上楼用剑刺向自己，但他的动作并不怎么利落。人们发现后，他的朋友们试图为他的胃部缝合伤口。当只剩他一个人时，他亲手扯开缝合线——哦，汤姆！——掏出自己的内脏，死得极其凄惨。是的，但也极其崇高。凯撒抵达乌蒂卡后，有人带他去看了加图的尸体。他站在遗体旁说道：“加图，正如你嫉妒我给予你活命的机会，我也嫉妒你拥有这样的死法。”由此产生了一种感觉：尽管凯撒击败了所有其他的敌人，但从某种意义上说，加图却战胜了他。
Right. Yeah. By not submitting, by not playing by Caesar's rules, by Caesar's new rules. Absolutely. And so within days, within weeks of it being reported back in Rome, Cato has become a kind of victorious emblem, even in defeat. And this is something that will reverberate through Roman history. So Lucan, who writes a great epic about the civil war in the time of Nero, he has this famous phrase, Victrix causa deus placuit sed victor catoni, the gods favoured the winning cause, but Cato favoured the defeated one. So Cato, in a sense, you know, his opinion, his approval is even more important than that of the gods. And this for Caesar is infuriating. And it prompts him to make a mistake. So when he goes
没错。是的。通过不妥协，通过不按凯撒的规矩——凯撒的新规矩办事。完全正确。因此，就在消息传回罗马后的几天、几周内，加图在失败中反而变成了一个胜利的象征。这将对罗马历史产生深远的影响。因此，在尼禄时代撰写关于内战的宏大史诗的卢坎（Lucan）留下了那句名言：“顺从胜者之意固然令神明愉悦，但加图却倾心于败者。”（Victrix causa deis placuit sed victori Catoni）因此，在某种意义上，加图的观点、他的赞许甚至比神明的意愿还要重要。这让凯撒感到愤怒至极。这也促使他犯下了一个错误。所以，当他
back to Rome from Africa, he stages four great triumphs. So triumphs are kind of military processions through the streets of Rome. He celebrates his victories in Gaul. Yeah. He celebrates his victories in Egypt. You know, this is the kind of Cleopatra in Broilio. Yeah. He celebrates victories in Asia, where he has his famous phrase, Veni Vidi Vici, paraded through the streets of Rome.
从非洲回到罗马后，他举办了四场盛大的凯旋式。凯旋式是一种穿过罗马街道的军队游行。他庆祝自己在高卢的胜利。是的。他庆祝自己在埃及的胜利。（这其中就夹杂着与克利奥帕特拉的绯闻。）是的。他庆祝自己在亚洲的胜利，在那里他留下了那句名言：“我来，我见，我征服”（Veni Vidi Vici），并在罗马街头游行展示。
I came, I saw, I conquered. A very, very quick victory. And this is a kind of a gloat over Pompey, because Pompey had made his name in Asia. And Caesar is basically saying, it's nothing. I mean, anyone could win a victory here. And then he celebrates his victory in Africa. And it is very, very offensive to contemplate that anyone might celebrate a triumph over fellow Romans. So Caesar is pretending that in Africa, he's been fighting Africans. Of course, he hasn't. He's actually been fighting
我来，我见，我征服。这是一场极其迅速的胜利。这其实是在对庞培进行的一种幸灾乐祸的炫耀，因为庞培当年正是在亚洲树立了自己的名望。凯撒基本上是在说：“这算不了什么。任何人都能在这里取得胜利。”然后，他庆祝了在非洲的胜利。然而，一想到有人竟然会为战胜同胞罗马人而举行凯旋式，人们就会感到非常反感。因此，凯撒假装自己在非洲是在与非洲人作战。当然，他并没有这样做。他实际上是在与
Romans. He kind of, he draws a veil over that. But because Cato has basically kind of driven him mad, he's the one guy who's got under his skin. Through the streets of Rome during this triumph, a float is drawn that illustrates the suicide of Cato. And the impact of this on the watching crowds, who normally are very pro-Caesar. You know, Caesar is bestowing great less on them and parades. It's all great fun. But the sight of this, they weep. And Caesar is kind of left furious by this. And he then goes off to Spain because the sons of Pompey the Great are there still holding out. This is going to be, you know, this is the last holdout of those who are resisting Caesar. And back in Rome, a figure decides that he is going to write a eulogy on Cato. And this figure is someone who is very close to Caesar. So he's called Marcus Junius Brutus.
罗马人作战。他把这一点轻描淡写地掩盖过去了。但由于加图简直把他逼疯了——加图是唯一一个能让他感到芒刺在背的人——在这场凯旋式的罗马街头游行中，有一辆花车描绘了加图自杀的场景。这一幕对围观群众产生了巨大的冲击，尽管他们平时对凯撒非常支持。（你知道的，凯撒向他们大肆封赏并举行游行，大家觉得这都挺好玩的。）但看到这个场景时，他们却失声痛哭。这让凯撒感到愤怒不已。随后他动身前往西班牙，因为伟大庞培的儿子们还在那里负隅顽抗。这将是……（你知道的，这是抵抗凯撒之力的最后一处坚守据点。）与此同时，在罗马，有一个人决定要为加图撰写一篇悼词。而这个人与凯撒的关系非常亲密。他名叫马库斯·尤尼乌斯·布鲁图斯（Marcus Junius Brutus）。
He is the son of Seville, who is Caesar's great love, the great love of his life. So almost like his sort of his schoolboy crush or his girlfriend when he was young. Is that right? Something like that? Yeah. They've had a kind of ongoing relationship through for a long time.
他是塞维利亚（Servilia）的儿子，而塞维利亚正是凯撒一生的挚爱，是他生命中最大的挚爱。所以，这几乎就像是他少年时的暗恋对象或是年轻时的女朋友？是这样吗？差不多是这样吧？是的。他们长期以来一直保持着某种持续的关系。
I mean, she's the woman who seems always to have been most fond of and there are rumors that that brutus might be caesar's son yeah so you'd think that that in the civil war brutus would immediately have signed sided with caesar but he doesn't because he is cato's nephew and so he is inspired by Cato's example to oppose Caesar. At the Battle of Pharsalus, where Caesar defeats Pompey, Caesar is very anxious about what has happened to Brutus and orders search parties to go out and find him. And when they find that he hasn't been killed, comes into Caesar's presence. Caesar hugs him, pardons him, bestows honors on him. And so Brutus is now very much a part of the regime that Caesar is trying to set up. I mean, to us, that does show Caesar in an extraordinarily magnanimous light because a lot of people in history that we have talked about, so not 21st
我的意思是，她似乎一直是凯撒最深爱的女人，而且有传言说布鲁图斯其实是凯撒的儿子。所以你会认为，在内战期间，布鲁图斯理应立刻倒向凯撒，但他并没有这么做，因为他是加图的外甥，因此他受到加图榜样的鼓舞而选择反对凯撒。在凯撒击败庞培的法萨卢斯战役中，凯撒对布鲁图斯的安危忧心忡忡，并下令搜救队出去寻找他的下落。当得知他没有阵亡并被带到凯撒面前时，凯撒拥抱了他，赦免了他，并授予他各种荣誉。因此，此时的布鲁图斯已经成为了凯撒努力建立的政权的重要组成部分。我的意思是，对我们而言，这确实将凯撒展现得极其宽宏大量，因为我们在历史上谈论过的许多人——不是指21世纪的人，而是中世纪的国王之类——会用即刻处死、酷刑或流放来惩罚这种行为。但凯撒的态度是如此非同寻常，他觉得：“好吧，你本来可以支持我，但你支持了另一个人。没关系，大家还是朋友，我很高兴你安然无恙。”我的意思是，他竟然会这么做，这真是对其心理的一次非凡洞察。是的。我认为这确实是真诚的——我的意思是，这是凯撒性格中非常非常富有同情心的一面。他不是暴君。他不会处死异己。他还让人重新树立起那些被他狂热的追随者推倒的庞培雕像。而且，正如你所见，他表现出了这种“仁慈”（Clementia），这在加图这样的人看来是极其冒犯的。
century people, but medieval kings or whatever, would have punished that with instant death or torture or exile. But Caesar's, it's extraordinary that his attitude is, well, you could have backed me, but you backed the other guy. That's fine. We're all friends. I'm so glad you're all right. I mean, what an extraordinary insight into his psychology that he would do that. Yeah. And I think it is a genuine, I mean, I mean, it is very, very sympathetic aspect of Caesar's character. He's not a tyrant. He doesn't put people to death. He raises Pompey statues that have been toppled by his enthusiastic followers. And, you know, he does show this Clementia, which to someone like Cato is deeply offensive.
但在其他人看来，这总比被杀、被没收财产并流放要好得多，而且还能被授予荣誉。但对布鲁图斯，凯撒似乎尤其……他特别喜爱布鲁图斯，因此也格外高兴能这样对待他。那么，布鲁图斯是个可爱的人吗？我的意思是，他也相当保守，对吧？有点像……他是个渴望成为加图的人。他非常一本正经，充满责任感，
But to others, you know, it's better than being killed, being parted and being given honours. But with Brutus, particularly, he seems to have been, you know, he's particularly fond of Brutus and therefore particularly kind of happy about it. So Brutus, is Brutus a lovable person? I mean, he's quite conservative too, isn't he? Like a bit like he's a sort of wannabe Cato. He's very earnest. He's very dutiful.
思想深邃，是个哲学家。他也是在共和国建立之初推翻君主制的那位伟人的后代。因此他有着强烈的使命感。我的意思是，这也是为什么我认为他会站在元老院精英一边。这也是为什么加图之死——他的舅舅之死——的榜样对他产生了特殊的影响。因此在此之后，他与自己的妻子离婚，娶了加图的女儿。这种行为未免太奇怪了吧？
He's very deep thinking. He's a philosopher. He is also descended from the man who overthrew the monarchy at the beginning of the Republic. So he's very conscious. I mean, this is another reason why I think he sides with the kind of the senatorial elites. And it's why the example of Cato's death, his uncle's death, has a particular impact on him. And so in the wake of that, he divorces his own wife and marries Cato's daughter. That's strange behaviour.
按我们的标准来看确实如此。他有点迷恋加图。好吧，罗马人比我们更容易离婚和再婚。得多得多。所以这部分上是一种文化现象。但我同意，这确实是在发表一种引人注目的声明。而波西亚（Portia）——加图的女儿，
By our standards, it is. He's a bit obsessed with Cato. Well, the Romans are much ready to divorce and remarry than we are. Much ready. So it's a kind of a cultural thing, partly. But I agree. I mean, it is making a striking statement. And Portia, who is Cato's daughter,
绝对是其父的翻版。我的意思是，她堪称坚贞的罗马主妇的典范。因此，我认为他们组成了一对非常具有道德感、略显冷漠且拒人于千里之外的夫妻。你不会邀请他们去参加晚宴吧？如果你对哲学、探讨古代罗马历史之类的话题感兴趣的话，或许会吧。我觉得我会很喜欢。你会去，但我可不会。我想我会去的。但不仅如此，他还为加图写了一篇讣告。
is absolutely a chip off the old block. I mean, she's the model of standing Roman matron. And so they make a very kind of moral and slightly chilly and forbidding pair, I think. You wouldn't invite them to a dinner party? Well, you might if you're interested in philosophy and discoursing on ancient Roman history and things. I think I'd enjoy that. So you would, but I wouldn't. I think I would. But what he also does is he writes an obituary for Cato.
他还找了另一个人也为加图写了一篇讣告。那个人并不是天生勇敢，一直缩着头，基本上一直在唉声叹气，巴不得整件事从未发生过。这个人就是罗马最著名的演说家，名叫西塞罗（Cicero）。西塞罗这个人基本上……他是个外地人。他的祖辈中没有人进入过元老院。他不仅成功进入了元老院，最终还当上了执政官。但他总是对这样一个事实耿耿于怀：自己生活在那些出身更高贵、地位更崇高——如果你愿意的话，比他更具“元老院气派”——的人的阴影之下。他和加图的关系有点冷淡，他既有点嫉妒加图，又有点……
And he gets someone else to write an obituary for Cato as well. Someone who is not naturally brave, who's been hunkering down, who's been basically kind of wringing his hands, wishing that the whole thing would go away. And this is Rome's most celebrated orator, a man called Cicero. And Cicero is a man who has basically, he's an out of towner. He is, none of his forebears have made it to the Senate. He is the guy who has not only made it to the Senate, but ended up as consul. But he's always kind of very conscious of the fact that he's in the shadow of people who are grander who are uh kind of more elevated more more senatorial if you like than him and he's had a slightly kind of chilly relationship with kato he's a little bit jealous of kato a little bit
而且他也能看出加图身上其实有一种隐隐的荒谬感，我是这么觉得的。西塞罗是一个非常有趣、机敏、精明的人，但天生一点也不英勇。不过他在布鲁图斯的劝说下，做了一件带有中度英雄色彩的事——稍微把脖子伸出去冒点险。那就是也为加图写一篇颂词。有关这件事的消息传到了远在西班牙的凯撒耳中，那里的战斗非常非常残酷。所以我们刚才谈到凯撒通常是个宽宏大量的人。但在西班牙，他可一点也不这样。与庞培儿子的战斗异常惨烈。他在公元前45年3月于蒙达（Munda）赢下了一场极其壮观的内战最后一战，并且他允许将所有阵亡对手的尸体——所有人都是罗马人，所有人都是公民——基本上当作建筑材料来使用。
he can also see that there's something faintly ridiculous about Cato, I think. Cicero is a very funny, alert, astute, intelligent man, but not naturally heroic at all. But he is persuaded by Brutus to do something that is moderately heroic, to kind of stick his neck out a little bit. And that is also to write a eulogy to Cato. And the news of this is brought to Caesar in Spain, where the fighting is very, very brutal. So we've talked about how Caesar is generally a magnanimous man. In Spain, he isn't at all. The fighting against Pompey's sons is very, very savage. He wins a spectacular battle, the last battle of the Civil War at a place called Munda in march 45 and he allows the corpses of his dead opponents all of whom are romans all of whom are citizens to basically be used as building materials
所以他们的尸体被捣碎拌进水泥和泥土里，用来修建凯撒的防御工事……就像卡车司机工会主席吉米·霍法（Jimmy Hoffa）那样？是的，非常像吉米·霍法。但吉米·霍法可不像……吉米·霍法会砍下人头插在长矛上庆祝胜利吗？据我所知不会。据我所知不会。我的意思是，我不认为1950年代的工会或劳工组织会有那么残忍，没有的。所以，猎取人头的做法在罗马人看来通常是与野蛮人联系在一起的。这不是罗马人应该做的事。
so their their bodies are kind of mulched up into the cement and the dirt that caesar is using to build fortifications like jimmy hoffer the head of the teamsters yes very like jimmy hoffer but unlike did jim jimmy hoffer cut off heads and stick them on spikes to celebrate his victory? Not that I'm aware of. Not that I'm aware of. I mean, I don't think trade unions, labour unions in the 1950s or whatever were quite that bad, no. So, I mean, the idea of headhunting is very kind of associated by the Romans with barbarians. It's not the kind of thing that Romans should be doing.
但凯撒之所以这样做，基本上是因为他受够了。他厌倦了这种没完没了的反对。此时消息传到他耳中，先是西塞罗写了东西就够糟糕的了，接着连布鲁图斯也为加图写了这些悼词，这彻底激怒了他。于是他亲自动笔写了一篇反驳文章——《反加图》（Anti-Cato）——基本上就是对加图进行恶毒的人身攻击，试图将他塑造成尽可能负面的形象，然后把文章送回罗马，结果基本上所有人都当笑话看了。当然，这更加激怒了凯撒。因此，即使凯撒所有的敌人都已被消灭，那种感觉依然挥之不去：加图正在从坟墓的彼端领导着反对派。这种氛围反过来激励了罗马城内那些曾与凯撒作战、或许已经接受了他赦免的人。
But Caesar does it basically because he's, you know, he's fed up. He's fed up with this relentless opposition. And the news is brought to him that Cicero, bad enough, but then Brutus has written these ulities to Cato and he's furious and he pens a riposte anti-Cato, kind of basically slagging Cato off, trying to cast him in as negative a light as possible, sends it back to Rome and basically everyone laughs. And of course, that infuriates Caesar even more. So there is this sense that even though all Caesar's enemies have been killed from beyond the grave, Cato is leading the opposition. And this kind of inspires people back in Rome who've been fighting Caesar, who may have accepted his pardon.
这既让他们感到宽慰，同时也让他们感到羞愧，意识到仍然有一场仗要去打。所以，当他们在罗马时，凯撒已经在西班牙获胜，随后他便回到了罗马，不是吗？所以他一定是在公元前44年转折之际左右回来的？这也是让罗马城内元老院精英感到被冒犯的另一件事，那就是他并没有急着赶回来。从西班牙出发后，他先是穿过了南高卢。当他在高卢时，他向高卢的许多名流授予了公民权，这其实是一项极具前瞻性的政策。他有一种意识，那就是罗马实际上是一个非常……（这是一个极具前瞻性的政策。他认为罗马现在是一个全球帝国。）
But it kind of it both reassures them, but also shames them into a sense that there is still a fight to be fought. So they're there in Rome and Caesar has won in Spain. He comes back to Rome, doesn't he? So he must come back in the turn of 44 BC, thereabouts? So this is another thing that offends the senatorial elite back in Rome, is that he does not hurry back. So from Spain, he kind of goes through southern Gaul. And while he's in Gaul, he offers citizenship to various Gallic luminaries, which is actually a very kind of forward-thinking policy. He has this sense that Rome is actually a very kind of, you know, forward thinking policy. He has this sense that Rome is now a global empire.
因此，仅仅将公民权赋予在罗马出生的人已经不够了。公民权正在向全意大利普及。但现在凯撒甚至开始把它发给高卢人了。这让罗马的精英们感到十分冒犯。他们一点也不喜欢这样。随后他率军进入意大利，在抵达罗马之前，在意大利迎面遇到了埃及女王克利奥帕特拉。他曾在亚历山大让这位女王怀孕，而她带着儿子来到了意大利。这再次表明，这一切的行为极其不符合共和政体的规范，因为克利奥帕特拉是个希腊人。她是一个女人。她是一个
And so it's not enough that citizenship should belong only to people born in Rome. So citizenship is spread throughout Italy. But Caesar is now handing it out to Gauls as well. But this is very offensive to the elites back in Rome. You know, they don't like it at all. And then he marches into Italy and he is met in Italy before he has reached Rome by Cleopatra, the queen of Egypt, who he had got pregnant in Alexandria and who was turned up in Italy with her son. And it's all, again, very, very un-Republican behaviour because Cleopatra is Greek. She's a woman. She's a
女王。我的意思是，对元老院议员来说，没有什么比凯撒宁愿把时间花在她身上而不是他们身上更让他们感到被冒犯的了。所以他一直在和她厮混，直到十月份——蒙达战役是在三月——他才抵达罗马。正是在这个时候，汤姆，我们的同胞们是不是已经——部分由于克利奥帕特拉的关系，正如你所说，她是一个极端富庶国度的外国希腊女王，而这个国度在罗马已经开始某种程度上代表着奢侈、放纵、腐败等等——罗马人当时是否已经在议论凯撒了：他想自立为王，他的行为不像个罗马人，他是个暴君，诸如此类？还是说这要在晚些时候才出现？
queen. I mean, it couldn't be more offensive to senators, the fact that Caesar would prefer to spend time with her rather than with them. And so he's hanging out with her and it's only in October. So the Battle of Munda was in March. It's only in October that he reaches Rome. And at this point, Tom, our people already, partly because of the association with Cleopatra, who, as you said, is a foreign Greek queen of an extremely rich realm, and one that in Rome has already come to sort of represent luxury, dissipation, corruption, and so on. Are people in Rome already saying of Caesar, he wants to make himself king, he is behaving in an un-Roman way, he's a despot, and all that sort of thing? Or does that come later?
是的，因为这里存在一个巨大的难题：你该如何消化凯撒如今占据的压倒性地位？我的意思是，这比庞培当年要庞大得多得多。他让所有人都笼罩在自己的阴影之下。因此西塞罗评价他说：“我们是他的奴隶，而他是这个时代的奴隶。”因此，对于他所面临的挑战，人们还有一些同情。但同时也存在着巨大的敌意。一个身后拥有如此众多军团的人，究竟该如何被重塑并融入共和国的体制之中呢？而答案则是那种经典的罗马式解决方案——每当面临危机时，你不是向前看，而是向后看。哪怕是对凯撒这样激进且胆大妄为的人来说也是如此。因此，在当时的大环境里，
Yes, because there's a huge problem, which is how do you digest the preponderant position that Caesar now has? I mean, it's much, much greater than Pompey had. He's put everyone in his shadow. And so Cicero says of him that, you know, we are his slaves, but he is the slave of the time. So there is some sympathy for the challenges that he faces. But there's also a lot of hostility. How can someone who has all these legions at his back, how can he be moulded into the fabric of the Republic? And the answer is the kind of the classic Roman one, which is always in times of crisis, you don't look forwards, you look backwards. And this is true even of someone as radical and daring as Caesar. So there is in the frame,
在共和国的宪法框架内，确实存在着这样一种机制：为了拯救共和国，可以赋予某人最高权力，某种程度上（你知道的）可以超越传统的行政官体制，任期为六个月。这个职位的名称所有听众都会非常熟悉——独裁官（dictator）。现在，对我们来说，问题在于当我们听到“独裁者”这个词时，我们想到的往往是希特勒或斯大林。请试着把这些从脑海中抹去。因为罗马的独裁官是被任命六个月以拯救共和国的人。而且在罗马历史的各个历史时期，这种情况都是定期发生的。这是符合宪法制裁的。而凯撒，早在公元前49年跨越卢比孔河之后，他就已经被任命为11天的独裁官了。在公元前48年10月，他被任命为一个整年的独裁官。
in the constitution of the Republic, there is scope for someone to be given supreme power, kind of, you know, overriding the traditional system of magistracies for six months. And the name of this office is one that all listeners will be very familiar with, dictator. Now, the problem for us, I think, is that when we hear the word dictator, we think of Hitler or Stalin. Try and remove that from your minds. Because a dictator is someone who is appointed for six months to save the Republic. And it's happened at kind of periodic intervals throughout Roman history. It is constitutionally sanctioned. And Caesar, he's already been appointed dictator for 11 days back in 49, in the wake of the crossing of the Rubicon. In October 48, he'd been appointed dictator for a year.
所以，这也是……（你知道的）符合宪法的，只不过任期是一年而不是六个月。然后到了公元前46年春天——也就是他前往非洲攻打西皮奥和加图的同一时期——他被任命为十年的独裁官。这赋予了他提名共和国所有行政官的权力。他被指定了一位马匹长官（master of horse），也就是他的副手，一个名叫雷必达（Lepidus）的人。因此雷必达在罗马境内被赋予了军事权威。同样，让所有人感到好笑的是，凯撒还被册封为“道德监察官”（prefect of morals）。
So that, again, is kind of, you know, it's constitutional, but it's for a year rather than six months. And then spring 46, so the same time as he's going off to fight Scipio and Cato in Africa, he's appointed dictator for 10 years. And this gives him the right to nominate all the Republic's magistrates. He's given a master of horse, which is his deputy, who's a man called Lepidus. So Lepidus is kind of given a military authority within Rome. Also, much to everyone's amusement, Caesar is created prefect of morals.
所以，这再次说明，你知道的，这是符合宪法的，只不过是一年而不是六个月。然后到了公元前46年春季，也就是他去非洲与西庇阿和小加图作战的同一时期，他被任命为十年的独裁官。这赋予了他提名共和国所有长官的权利。他被赋予了一名马长官，也就是他的副手，一个名叫雷必达的人。因此，雷必达在罗马境内获得了一定的军事权力。此外，令所有人大跌眼镜的是，凯撒被任命为道德监察官。
Caesar is not a moral man. He's a massive shagger. I mean, he's very promiscuous. He never stops. And so the question is, are these positions sufficient to keep Caesar happy? And when he comes back to Rome, it's kind of evident that they're not really, that they're not sufficient for the preponderant role that Caesar has in the Republic. And so people start giving him ever more honours, ever more titles. But there is a sense in which by doing that, it's a little bit like garlanding a sacrificial bull. Because the more honours they give, the more the Republic comes to see him as cipher, the more Caesar is provoking the envy and the hostility of his peers with consequences that will play out very, very bloodily over the few months that remain of Caesar's life following his return to Rome in October 45 BC. Well, that's the perfect place, Tom,
凯撒不是一个道德高尚的人。他是个超级花心大萝卜。我的意思是，他非常风流。他从不收敛。所以问题是，这些职位足以让凯撒满意吗？当他回到罗马时，很明显，它们其实并不足够，对于凯撒在共和国中所占据的压倒性地位而言，这些是远远不够的。因此，人们开始给他越来越多的荣誉，越来越多的头衔。但某种意义上说，这样做有点像在给一头献祭的公牛戴上花环。因为他们给的荣誉越多，共和国就越觉得他是个傀儡，凯撒就越是激起同僚们的嫉妒和敌意，而这些后果将在公元前45年10月凯撒回到罗马后剩下的几个月里，以非常非常血腥的方式上演。好了，这是个绝佳的时机，汤姆，
on which to take a break. So Julius Caesar has about six months left, doesn't he? And we will be telling the story of those six months and what happens to him in the second half of the podcast. So come back after the adverts. Bye-bye. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman.
我们可以在这里休息一下。所以朱利叶斯·凯撒大约还剩六个月的时间，对吧？我们将在播客的下半部分讲述这六个月的故事以及他身上发生了什么。广告之后见。再见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。
And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. We are in the final stretch of the extraordinary and colourful
我们共同主持《娱乐即全部》。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论、一点八卦绯闻，在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想收听无广告节目、独家番外并优先购买现场门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史即全部》。我们正处于非凡、多姿多彩
and ultimately doomed life of Julius Caesar, who has become dictator in Rome. Now, Tom, tell us a little bit. What are his plans? What's he trying to do? Well, he comes back and he displays the kind of incredible, almost demonic energy that he has done throughout his whole life. And he is aware that Rome and the people of Rome face all kinds of problems. And so with the power that he now has and that previous generations of Roman statesmen didn't have because they were always having to kind of watch their back and cope with the jealousies of people who were their peers.
且最终注定走向毁灭的朱利叶斯·凯撒一生的最后冲刺阶段，他已经在罗马成为了独裁者。那么，汤姆，给我们讲讲。他的计划是什么？他想做什么？好吧，他回来了，并表现出一种难以置信的、几乎是恶魔般的精力，他在自己的一生中一直如此。他意识到罗马和罗马人民面临着各种各样的问题。因此，凭借他现在拥有的权力，以及前几代罗马政治家所没有的权力——因为他们总是不得不谨小慎微，应付同僚们的嫉妒——
Now he can kind of basically force through what he wants. So he plans all kinds of urban improvements. Pompey has built Rome's first theatre of stone, a vast great structure. Caesar inevitably plans a theatre that's going to be larger than that um he plans the largest temperate in the world on the campus marshes which is um with traditionally the place where um the the people of rome would would mass for for warfare but has long since become a kind of place for urban development um he plans to move the tiber to expedite his building schemes. So that's the kind of the measure of, you know, his sense of self-confidence. He famously revises the calendar. So the Julian calendar, this is the a vast city of almost a million people. They need to be kept fed. And Caesar is concerned to improve the condition of the people. That's why the people of Rome love him. Because he's always been a populist. He is a populist. Yeah, playing to the crowds. Yes. So he's kind of pushing through policies that are very effective and that perhaps it took an autocrat to push through.
现在他基本上可以强行推行他想要的东西了。所以他计划了各种各样的城市改造。庞培建造了罗马的第一座石质剧院，这是一座宏伟的巨大建筑。凯撒不可避免地计划建造一座比那更大的剧院；嗯，他计划在战神广场建造世界上最大的神庙，那传统上是罗马人民为战争而集结的地方，但早已变成了一种城市发展的地方；嗯，他计划改道台伯河以加快他的建设方案。所以这就是他自信心的一种衡量标准。他闻名遐迩地修改了历法。这就是儒略历，这是一个拥有近百万人口的庞大城市。必须让他们有饭吃。凯撒关心的改善人民的状况。这就是为什么罗马人民爱戴他。因为他一直是个民粹主义者。他就是一个民粹主义者。是的，迎合大众。是的。所以他一直在推行非常有效的政策，而这些政策也许需要一个独裁者才能推行。
And he's also looking abroad. So he's founding colonies across the Mediterranean, particularly two cities that have been wiped out by the Romans a century before, the great city of Carthage and the city of Corinth. He plants colonies there. But I think there's also a sense that, you know, even a few months back in Rome, he's already bored of, he finds Rome almost parochial. And also he finds the problem of his position in Rome to be too great. And so, remember, we mentioned Crassus, his kind of former colleague in the triumvirate, had been killed there in a great battle. Caesar decides that he's going to lead a campaign against the Parthians.
他还在放眼海外。因此，他在整个地中海建立殖民地，特别是两个在一世纪前被罗马人彻底摧毁的城市，伟大的迦太基城和科林斯城。他在那里安置殖民地。但我也觉得，你知道，即使回到罗马才几个月，他已经开始感到厌烦了，他觉得罗马简直是个小地方。而且他还觉得自己在罗马的地位问题太大了。所以，记住，我们提到过克拉苏，他在三头同盟中的前同事，在那里的一场大战中丧生了。凯撒决定率领远征军讨伐帕提亚人。
And is there an element there, Tom, sorry, is there an element also of emulating Alexander the Great, another friend of the rest's history? So it is said. So there's a story that when Caesar is in his 30s, he sees a statue of Alexander and reflects that by this age, Alexander had conquered the world and he, Caesar, has done nothing. It's hard to know how much that's actually a motivating factor for Caesar himself. Pompey had been definitely influenced by Alexander.
汤姆，抱歉，这里面是不是也有一种效仿亚历山大大帝的成分？亚历山大是“历史即全部”的另一个老熟人了。据说如此。所以有一个故事说，凯撒在30多岁时，看到了一尊亚历山大的雕像，反思说在这个年纪，亚历山大已经征服了世界，而他凯撒却一事无成。很难知道这在多大程度上真正成为了凯撒本人的动机因素。庞培绝对受过亚历山大的影响。
I think Caesar less so. I think Caesar had sufficient confidence that really the inspiration for Caesar was Caesar. I think there's a sense in which he thinks in the East, he can play the role of a king much more easily because there, you because there people are happy to accept that a leader could be, you know, a kind of new Alexander. So in a way, by planning this campaign, he's kind of washing his hands of all the kind of the snarl, the pettiness as he sees it, the resentments that he's having to face in Rome, the kind of the pygmies that are kind of scrabbling around trying to pull him down and all this kind of thing um and so he plans a military expedition for which he's going to leave at the end of march yes and so for his his enemies they have to decide what are they going to do about this and there's a sense in the months that follow his return to rome in october 45 that you know his enemies are kind of they're torn between giving him honors to keep him happy
我认为凯撒受到的影响较小。我认为凯撒有足够的自信，凯撒真正的灵感来源其实就是凯撒本人。我认为某种意义上他认为在东方，他可以更容易地扮演国王的角色，因为在那里，人们很高兴地接受一个领导者可以，你知道，是一个类似新的亚历山大。所以在某种程度上，通过策划这次远征，他算是甩手不管了所有那些纷扰、在他看来琐碎的小事、他在罗马不得不面对的怨恨、那些试图把他拉下马的侏儒般的家伙以及所有这类事情；嗯，于是他计划了一场军事远征，他将在三月底出发。是的，所以对于他的敌人来说，他们必须决定该怎么做；在公元前45年10月他回到罗马后的几个月里，有一种感觉，你知道，他的敌人进退维谷，一方面要给他荣誉以讨他欢心，
and facing kind of a series of incidents that provoke all kinds of outrage in them so they they um late in 45 they give him divine honors they allow him to wear the name imperator which means a victorious general as his first name yeah Early in February, a really fateful step. He's appointed dictator perpetuous, dictator for life. And that really, for everyone in Rome is a kind of, you know, who believes in the future of the Republic is the kind of absolute death knell. Because if he's dictator for life, that means that there's no real prospect of restoring the Republic until he's gone. And, you know, a perpetual dictatorship implies a kind of perpetual crisis. Yeah. So it's not even as if it promises the Roman people a solution to its problems.
另一方面又要面对一系列引发他们各种愤怒的事件。所以他们在45年底给了他神圣的荣誉，允许他将“英白拉多”（意为凯旋将军）这个词作为他的名。是的。在二月初，一个真正命运攸关的步伐。他被任命为永久独裁者（dictator perpetuus）。这在罗马对每个人来说，尤其是对那些信仰共和国未来的人来说，简直是一个绝对的丧钟。因为如果他是永久独裁者，那就意味着在他在台期间，恢复共和国是毫无希望的。而且，你知道，永久独裁意味着一种永久的危机。是的。所以它甚至没有承诺给罗马人民一个解决问题的方案。
It kind of says that they are permanent. And that really is the, you know, that is what gets his enemies thinking we need to do something about this. But there are various kind of other incidents that fuel it as well. So he starts to appear wearing the wrong shoes, Dominic. Oh, no way. He starts wearing high red boots. So kingly boots. Kingly boots.
它某种程度上表明这些问题是永久性的。这才是真正让他的敌人开始思考“我们需要对此做点什么”的原因。但也有各种其他事件在推波助澜。比如他开始穿着错误的鞋子出现，多米尼克。哦，不会吧。他开始穿高筒红靴子。也就是帝王靴。帝王靴。
Kingly boots. Right. And so this, you know, it's not a good thing and then on the um on the 15th of february a great festival is celebrated in rome called the lupicalia yeah which we actually kind of discussed i think in the episode we did on the on valentine's day but just to reprise it involves naked men running around uh the uh the palatine into the forum lashing bare-breasted women with goat thongs. And usually it's young men who do this.
帝王靴。没错。所以这，你知道，这不是一件好事；然后在2月15日，罗马举行了一个盛大的节日，叫做牧神节（Lupercalia），是的，我们其实在情人节的那期节目中讨论过这个，但简单回顾一下，它涉及赤身裸体的男人在帕拉蒂尼山和广场周围奔跑，用皮鞭抽打着袒胸露乳的女人的胸部。通常都是年轻人做这件事。
They were different times, Tom. They were more or less in times. Yeah. I mean, who wouldn't enjoy seeing that? And it's mostly young men who are doing this. But on this occasion, there is a 40-year-old man who's doing it. And this is the man who has been Caesar's great lieutenant, right-hand man, and who in 44 BC has been appointed consul by Caesar.
那是不同的时代，汤姆。那是或多或少充满生机的时代。是啊。我的意思是，谁会不喜欢看这个呢？而且主要是年轻人这么做。但在这次活动中，有一个40岁的男人也在这样做。这个人就是凯撒伟大的副将、得力助手，并且在公元前44年被凯撒任命为执政官的人。
This is a man called Marcus Antonius, better known to us as Mark Antony. And Antony, you know, he goes running around the Palatine, lashing breasts with his goat thong and all that kind of stuff. Topless women. And then he comes into the Forum before the Senate House, which is actually in ruins because it had burnt down eight years before. So it's kind of the scaffolding and repairs everywhere. But Caesar is sitting in front of it.
这个人叫马库斯·安东尼乌斯，我们更熟悉的名字是马克·安东尼。安东尼，你知道，他绕着帕拉蒂尼山奔跑，用皮鞭抽打着女人的胸部等等。赤裸上胸的女人。然后他来到元老院大楼前的广场上，元老院大楼其实已经成了一片废墟，因为它八年前被烧毁了。所以到处都是脚手架和修缮的痕迹。但凯撒正坐在它前面。
And Antony approaches Caesar. And the gathered crowd see that Antony has in his hands a diadem that is entwined with laurel. And the diadem is the symbol of monarchy. And Antony stands there his hands a diadem that is entwined with laurel. And the diadem is the symbol of monarchy. And Antony stands there and waits for applause. And there is no applause. There's, you know, kind of dozletree clapping, but otherwise nothing. There's a long pause. And then Caesar orders Antony to put the diadem away. And as he does say, the forum erupts into tumultuous cheering. Doesn't Caesar say, take it to the temple of Jupiter because Jupiter is the only king of the Romans?
安东尼向凯撒走去。聚集的人群看到安东尼手里拿着一顶缠绕着月桂树的王冠（diadem）。王冠是君主制的象征。安东尼站在那里，等待掌声。但没有掌声。有的只是稀稀拉拉的掌声，除此之外什么也没有。现场陷入了长时间的沉默。然后凯撒命令安东尼把王冠拿走。就在他这么说的时候，广场上爆发出了雷鸣般的欢呼声。凯撒难道不是说，“把它拿到朱庇特神庙去，因为朱庇特才是罗马人唯一的国王”吗？
He does. So Antony tries to press it on him a second time. And that's when Caesar says that, yeah, Rome will have no other king. So if you're one of Caesar's critics, you think this is a put up job. Caesar was in on this. He was hoping that the crowd would cheer and he would become king. Is that right? Is that a plausible explanation for what was happening become king is that right is that is that
他确实这么说了。所以安东尼第二次试图把王冠强加给他。就在那时，凯撒说，是的，罗马不会再有别的国王。所以如果你是凯撒的批评者，你会认为这是一场自导自演的戏。凯撒参与其中了。他希望人群会欢呼，然后他就能当上国王。是这样吗？这是一个合理的解释吗？
a plausible explanation for what was happening yes i mean that that is what that's what his enemies say and he'd misjudged the the crowd yeah and i think it's very very plausible anything is true my hunch is about about caesar's plans he didn't really care um i think he is i think he's bored of everything to do with rome to be honest. He spent so long abroad in the saddle on campaign. He finds the kind of the pettiness of it all. It's a bit like, you know, it's a bit like when prime ministers enter their imperial phase and they're off going to summits and all that kind of thing. And then they have to come back and deal with local government acts. And it's just beneath them.
这是一个合理的解释吗？是的。我的意思是，这就是他的敌人们所说的，而且他当时误判了人群。是的，我认为这非常非常合理。任何事情都有可能是真的。我关于凯撒计划的直觉是，他根本不在乎；我觉得，老实说，他对罗马有关的一切都厌烦了。他在马鞍上、在战役中在国外度过了那么长时间。他觉得这一切都太琐碎了。这有点像，你知道，这有点像首相们进入他们的帝国阶段，他们到处去参加峰会和所有那些事情，然后他们不得不回来处理地方政府法案，而这简直有失他们的身份。
And I think he feels, you know, that he can rule as dictator at home in rome he can rule as you know a kind of quasi king abroad and you know he's not really interested in the republic so he notoriously he's you know he says that the republic is is a nothingness a name only that it has no body no substance uh and and i think that i think there is a kind of anxiety that he wants to make himself a king but i think it's also the feeling his enemies have that he despises them and everything that they hold dear and valuable yeah i mean caesar is pretty confident that he doesn't have to worry about them because he he his hunch is is that they know that anything that replaces him will be worse than him so he doesn't have a bodyguard um he knows so there's a guy called favonius who's
我觉得他觉得，你知道，他可以在罗马家里作为独裁者统治，他可以在国外作为某种准国王统治，你知道，他其实对共和国不感兴趣。因此，众所周知，他说共和国是一虚无，只是一个名字，它没有身体，没有实质；而且我认为，我认为有一种焦虑，他想让自己成为一个国王，但我也觉得他的敌人有种感觉，那就是他鄙视他们以及他们所珍视和看重的一切。是的，我的意思是凯撒非常自信，他不必担心他们，因为他的直觉是，他们知道任何取代他的东西都会比他更糟糕。所以他没有保镖；他知道——所以有一个叫法沃尼乌斯的家伙，他
who's a kind of models himself on the example of cato um and and he says that you know it's better to have better to have a tyrant than than a civil war and so caesar is pretty confident in that that he can rely on on his enemies not to to do to do something stupid this is the justification for autocrats right up to the present day so the autocrats of the of the 2020s their defenders will say well better a strong man who keeps everything who you know upholds law as long as he's not a complete tyrant better a strong man than these squabbling parliamentary pygmies you know that's that that's always the justification, isn't it? Yeah.
把自己的行为模式建立在加图的榜样之上，并且他说，你知道，拥有一个暴君总比发生内战要好。因此，凯撒非常自信，他可以指望他的敌人不会做出愚蠢的事情。这就是独裁者直到今天的辩护理由。因此，2020年代的独裁者的辩护者会说，好吧，一个保持一切稳定的强人总比这个好——只要他不是个彻头彻尾的暴君，一个维护法律的强人总比这些争吵不休的议会侏儒要好。你知道，这总是辩护的理由，不是吗？是的。
For a move towards authoritarianism. Yeah. And also, I think Caesar feels that he's offered his clemency to all these people. And so he can rely on that. So as we come to March 44, we have Caesar is dictator for life. We have Lepidus, who is his master of horse, effectively Caesar's deputy. Caesar and Antony are both consuls. But there is a guy called Dolabella, who is a Caesarian, who is his master of horse, effectively Caesar's deputy. Caesar and Antony are both consuls, but there is a guy called Dolabella, who is a Caesarian, who is consul designate. So he is kind of scheduled to replace Caesar when he goes abroad as consul. And he's the son-in-law of Cicero.
走向威权的借口。是的。而且，我认为凯撒觉得他已经向所有人展示了他的宽大处理。所以他可以依靠这一点。因此，当我们来到公元前44年3月时，我们有身为终身独裁者的凯撒。我们有雷必达，他是他的骑兵长官，实际上就是凯撒的副手。凯撒和安东尼都是执政官。但有一个叫多拉贝拉的家伙，他是一个凯撒党人，是候任执政官。所以他预定在凯撒出国担任执政官时接替凯撒。他是西塞罗的女婿。
I mentioned the praetors. These are the officials who are kind of directly below consuls in rank. So there are two particularly distinguished praetors these are the officials who are kind of directly below consuls in in rank so um there are two particularly distinguished praetors so one of them the urban praetor who is responsible for administering rome if the consuls aren't there um can only ever um leave rome for a maximum of 10 days the urban praetor is brutus who we've mentioned yeah then there is a praetor who essentially serves as the kind of the foreign minister the foreign secretary secretary of state um and this is a man called cassius longinus and cassius had uh fought with crassus and had distinguished himself there by bringing back the the remnants of crassus's defeated army um he had fought with pomy, been his best naval commander, been pardoned by Caesar.
我提到了裁判官。这些是官阶仅次于执政官的官员。所以有两个特别杰出的裁判官，这些是官阶仅次于执政官的官员；所以，其中一个城市裁判官负责在执政官不在时管理罗马，只能离开罗马最多10天。城市裁判官是布鲁图斯，我们之前提到过。是的。然后还有一个裁判官，基本上担任外交大臣、外交部长、国务卿的角色，这个人叫卡西乌斯·隆吉纳斯。卡西乌斯曾与克拉苏并肩作战，并在那里通过带回克拉苏战败军队的残余而崭露头角。他曾与庞培作战，是他最好的海军统帅，后被凯撒赦免。
And he is a lean and hungry man, as Shakespeare describes him. Yes. So he's generally portrayed as an envious, ambitious, frustrated, embittered man. Is that fair? Or is that a later read? No, I think there's a strong element of that. And Cassius and Brutus, of course, are the people who convene the conspiracy. Yeah.
正如莎士比亚所描述的，他是一个瘦削而饥饿的人。是的。所以他通常被描绘成一个嫉妒、雄心勃勃、受挫、痛苦的人。这公平吗？还是后来的解读？不，我认为其中有很大一部分成分。当然，卡西乌斯和布鲁图斯是密谋的发起者。是的。
There is debate among the sources as to whether it was Cassius who led it or Brutus. The version in Shakespeare, and therefore the one that's become canonical, is that it's Cassius who leads it as i said brutus is the heir of the man who expelled the monarchy and therefore kind of feels he has a particular responsibility for it there is a lot of dispute in the sources as to exactly how many conspirators there were so it ranges in number from 80 to about 15 right but those sources could accurately they could reflect the situation tom because if you've got a conspiracy like that absolutely you could have a lot of people who are vaguely aware of it and are sympathetic but are not really prime movers in the conspiracy yeah we're waiting to see how things play out absolutely and the that you know there are kind of various um although the main you know a bit like jesus we have four four principal accounts of caesar's death and they're
史料对于究竟是卡西乌斯领导了这场阴谋还是布鲁图斯领导的存有争议。莎士比亚版本中的版本，因此也是成为正统的版本，是卡西乌斯领导了它。正如我所说，布鲁图斯是驱逐君主制之人的后代，因此觉得他对这负有特殊的责任。史料中对于到底有多少密谋者存在很多争议，所以人数从80人到大约15人不等。但这些史料能准确反映情况吗，汤姆？因为如果你有这样一场阴谋，绝对会有很多人隐约知道并同情它，但并不是阴谋的核心推动者。是的，我们在等待事情的发展。绝对的。而且，你知道，虽然主要的（有点像耶稣，我们关于凯撒之死有四个主要记载），
written quite a long time after his death. But they clearly draw on contemporary sources. And I think the confusion that surrounds, you know, how many conspirators there were, who organized the conspiracy, what exactly happened, is reflective of the fact that, you know, conspiracies by their nature, as you said, are often kind of veiled in shadow. One person who's not embroiled in it is Cicero. Yeah. But somebody who is in, who, who,
它们是在他死后很久才写的。但它们显然借鉴了当代史料。我认为围绕有多少密谋者、谁组织了阴谋、究竟发生了什么等问题的混乱，反映了一个事实，即阴谋就其本质而言，正如你所说，往往隐藏在阴影中。西塞罗是没有卷入其中的一个人。是的。但有一个人卷入其中，
who is complicit in it is a man called Decimus Brutus who had fought with Caesar in Gaul and who's another, it gets very easy to confuse him with, with Marcus Junius Brutus because he, of him also, it said that he might've been Caesar's son. Because there are some, there are indeed some people who say that Caesar's famous words are actually not to Marcus Junius Brutus, but they are to Decimus Brutus when he's
是同谋的人是一个叫德西穆斯·布鲁图斯的人，他曾与凯撒在高卢并肩作战，这也是另一个人。把马库斯·容尼斯·布鲁图斯和他搞混非常容易，因为关于他，也有人说他可能是凯撒的儿子。因为确实有一些人说，凯撒的名言其实不是对马库斯·容尼斯·布鲁图斯说的，而是对德西穆斯·布鲁图斯说的，当时他
dying, when he's being stabbed. Yes. So on the night before the 15th of March, Caesar is having dinner with Decimus Brutus. They're at the house of Lepidus and the conversation turns to what the best death would be. You know, how best would it be to die? And Caesar answers abruptly and unexpectedly. And then he goes home. And the story is, is that he has strange dreams that he sees himself flying above the clouds, clasping the hand of Jupiter and his wife, Calpurnia. She imagines that she sees their house come crashing down.
快要死了，正在被刺杀。是的。所以3月15日的前夜，凯撒正与德西穆斯·布鲁图斯共进晚餐。他们在雷必达的家里，谈话转向了怎样的死法才是最好的。你知道，怎么死才是最好的？凯撒生硬而意外地回答了。然后他回家了。故事是这样的，他做了奇怪的梦，梦见自己飞翔在云端，紧握着朱庇特的手以及他的妻子卡尔帕尼娅。她想象自己看到他们的房子轰然倒塌。
She holds her husband, you know, hugs him and realises that he's been stabbed. And then it's said that the doors of their bedchamber fling open by an unseen hand. And so in the morning, again, it is said that this makes Caesar a bit worried. He decides that maybe he shouldn't go and decimus brutus turns up and persuades him to go they have to strike now the conspirators don't they because he's about to leave very soon yeah going to leave for path here and if he had left for path here and had a triumphant campaign their moment would have well and truly passed because then surely he would be in a position to become king. I mean, whether or not he calls himself king is irrelevant. So it's sort of now or never for them, I suppose. Well, it's really interesting. I mean,
她抱住她的丈夫，拥抱他，并意识到他被刺伤了。然后据说他们的卧室门被一只看不见的手猛地推开了。所以在早上，同样有人说这让凯撒有点担心。他决定也许他不应该去，但德西穆斯·布鲁图斯出现了并说服他去。密谋者们必须现在就动手，不是吗？因为他很快就要离开了。是的，他要去帕提亚。如果他去了帕提亚并取得了一场凯旋的战役，他们的时刻就会彻底过去。因为那样的话，他肯定会处于能够成为国王的地位。我的意思是，他是否自称国王是无关紧要的。所以对他们来说，这可以说是机不可失，失不再来。嗯，这真的很有趣。我的意思是，
of course, they could have employed someone to assassinate him while he was on campaign. But what's interesting, and this again, I think is what makes Caesar's murder so totemic, is that it's not some loner. It's not some agent. It's not some madman. It's not some paid assassin. It's the leading men of the state who do it. And just on their plan. So they obviously, by this point, have a very clear plan that they're going to do it
当然，他们本可以雇人在他远征时暗杀他。但有趣的是——这再次我认为使凯撒的谋杀如此具有象征意义的原因——不是某个独行侠。不是某个特工。不是某个疯子。不是某个花钱雇来的刺客。而是国家的领导阶层做了这件事。关于他们的计划。所以他们到这个时候显然有一个非常明确的计划，他们要在
at the meeting of the, pretty much the last meeting of the Senate before he goes off. Now I know they're meeting at the Theatre of Pompey, aren't they? Because as you said, the Senate House is being rebuilt rebuilt how much is it important to them that it's public that and it's in a political arena is that is that part of their is that a very conscious political gesture yes because that they are making a political statement rather in the way that kato
元老院几乎是他在离开前的最后一次会议上动手。我知道他们是在庞培剧院开会，对吧？因为正如你所说，元老院大楼正在重建。地点是公开的，并且在一个政治竞技场上，这对他们有多重要？那一部分是他们的——那是一个非常刻意的政治姿态吗？是的，因为他们是在发表政治声明，有点像加图
had done by ripping open his stomach right it's a spectacle of blood and liberty it can't be done kind of in the shadows right he's being sacrificed like a bull you know i said they they're lavishing all these honors on him they're kind of garlanding him and then leading him up to the altar and their plans so the very fact that you were telling us the stories about the dreams tells us something about the problems we have the sources doesn't it because the stories about the dreams are formulaic aren't they yeah i mean they're it's like omens you know they probably didn't even happen um i mean they might have done but they might not it's no way for us to know but from what we know of the sources can we have any sense of whether these guys
剖腹自杀所做的那样。这是一场血与自由的奇观。不能在阴影中进行。他像一头公牛一样被献祭，你知道，我说过，他们把所有这些荣誉挥霍在他身上，他们给他戴上花环，然后把他带到祭坛上。他们的计划——你刚才给我们讲的关于梦的故事说明了我们从史料中遇到的问题，不是吗？因为关于梦的故事是公式化的，不是吗？是的，我的意思是，它们就像是预兆，你知道，它们可能根本没有发生过。我的意思是，它们可能发生过，但也可能没有。我们无从得知。但从我们对史料的了解来看，我们能否感觉到这些家伙
have any sort of progressive practical plan for what happens after they've killed julius caesar no i mean they're certainly not progressive in many ways they're they're reactionary yeah practical plan for what happens after they've killed Julius Caesar? No. I mean, they're certainly not progressive. In many ways, they're reactionary. They assume that they will kill Caesar and the Republic will be restored. And Cicero, who approves of the murder, but they don't ask him because they're kind of worried about, you know, he's not really the kind of conspirator type. He will say in due course that they behaved like men, but they planned like children. So they have no real plan at all. However, I mean, it's amazing it doesn't kind of leak out. There are all kinds of presentiments.
对刺杀朱利叶斯·凯撒之后会发生什么有任何渐进的实际计划吗？不，我的意思是，他们在许多方面绝对不是渐进的，他们是反动的。是的。对于刺杀朱利叶斯·凯撒之后会发生什么有实际计划吗？不，我的意思是，他们绝对不是渐进的。在许多方面，他们是反动的。他们假设他们杀了凯撒，共和国就会恢复。而西塞罗赞成谋杀，但他们没有问他，因为他们有点担心，你知道，他真不是那种阴谋家的类型。他后来会说，他们表现得像个男人，但计划得像个孩子。所以他们根本没有什么真正的计划。然而，我的意思是，这件事没有走漏风声真是太惊人了。有各种各样的预感。
So famously, again, people who have seen the Shakespeare play will remember there's a fortune teller called, a soothsayer called Spirina who warns Caesar, beware the Ides of March. So that detail, is that fiction, Tom? Is that made up? I don't know. I don't know. I mean, Caesar's death is such a seismic event. And it is seen as one that reverberates through the heavens as well as through the earth, as we will see in due course. It kind of upsets the entire fabric of the cosmos from the heavens to the earth. Of course, people would assume that it had been foretold. I don't know. Sorry, I interrupted you anyway.
所以再次众所周知，看过莎士比亚戏剧的人会记得有一个算命先生，一个叫斯皮里纳的预言家警告凯撒，小心三月十五日。所以这个细节是虚构的吗，汤姆？那是编造的吗？我不知道。我不知道。我的意思是，凯撒之死是一场如此震撼的事件。它被视为一件在天界和人间都引起共鸣的事，正如我们随后将看到的。它扰乱了从天堂到大地的整个宇宙结构。当然，人们会认为这是预先注定的。我不知道。抱歉，无论如何我打断了你。
You were saying he goes with Decimus. So as he's going with Decimus to the Theatre of Pompey where the Senate are meeting, he sees Spirina and he says, you know, the Ides of March have come and here I am fine. And Spirina turns around and says, they have come, Caesar, but they are not yet gone. So Caesar goes into the Senate House, which Pompey had built as part of his great complex. So there's a theatre, then there are gardens, and then there's this kind of great marble hall with the Senate House. And there's a large statue of Pompey in the Senate House. Caesar has ordered it to be booked up. Nearby, there are games going on.
你刚才说他和德西穆斯一起去。当他和德西穆斯一起去元老院开会的庞培剧院时，他看到了斯皮里纳，他说，你知道，三月十五日已经到了，我这不是好好的吗。斯皮里纳转过身说，它们是到了，凯撒，但它们还没过去。所以凯撒走进了元老院大楼，那是庞培作为其伟大建筑群的一部分建造的。所以有一个剧院，然后有花园，然后是这个带有元老院大楼的宏伟的大理石大厅。元老院大楼里有一尊庞培的大雕像。凯撒下令将其固定好。附近正在举行运动会。
So there are kind of cheers, spectacles of blood. This is the kind of the background. And then as Caesar walks into the Senate House itself, these sounds dim. The conspirators are aware that there is a potential threat to them in the figure of Antony. And so one of the conspirators is employed to distract him and not go in with Caesar. There are various people who are identified as having done that, but the likeliest candidate is a man called Trebonius, who we'll feature in due course later in the story. So Caesar goes in, the senators rise
因此，现场既有欢呼声，也有血腥的奇观。这就是当时的背景。当凯撒走进元老院大楼本身时，这些声音渐渐减弱了。阴谋分子意识到安东尼的存在对他们构成了潜在的威胁。因此，其中一名阴谋分子被安排去引开他，不与凯撒一同进去。有几个人被认为做了这件事，但最有可能的人选是一个名叫特雷波尼乌斯的人，我们将在故事接下来的适当时候详细介绍他。于是凯撒走了进去，元老们起立
to greet him, a mark of respect that Caesar himself had not shown the senator a few weeks earlier. So he has a special chair, does he? A sort of throne type chair? Yes. But this is, so if you imagine, it's kind of like before the meeting of a committee. So the senators are kind of milling around, there are kind of little groups. It's like the guy who's going to chair the committee has arrived, but the meeting has not yet properly begun. And so there is scope for people to come up and ask Caesar for favours, because government in the Republic is very, very personal. So if you want a favour done, you have to approach Caesar personally. And we don't know how many senators there are, but hundreds of them. So
向他致意，这是凯撒本人几周前没有向元老院展示的尊重。所以他有一把特殊的椅子，对吧？某种宝座式的椅子？是的。但这是，所以如果你想象一下，这有点像委员会开会之前。所以元老院成员们到处闲逛，有一些小群体。这就像将要主持委员会的人已经到了，但会议还没有正式开始。因此，人们有机会走过来请求凯撒帮忙，因为共和国的政府非常非常个人化。所以如果你想得到帮助，你必须亲自接近凯撒。我们不知道有多少元老院成员，但有几百个。所以
the numbers have been hugely inflated. There were about 900 at this point. Crikey. But they're not all there, surely? No, they're probably not all there. So there've been 300 a few decades previously, and now it's about 900 because it's been inflated by Caesar. So you never see that in cinematic adaptations where there are sort of 50 people. So it's a real kind of House of Commons, House of Representatives type scene. Yes, I think so. And so people come up to Caesar
人数大大膨胀了。当时大约有900人。天哪。但他们不可能都去吧？不，他们可能没有全到。所以几十年前有300人，现在大约有900人，因为被凯撒扩编了。所以你在电影改编中永远看不到这一点，那里只有大约50人。所以这真是一个下议院、众议院类型的场景。是的，我想是的。所以人们走近凯撒
and one of them is a guy, as you said in your account, Tilius Kimber, who approaches with a petition and then he grabs Caesar's toga. And then a guy called Casca seems stabs him below the throat. And the blows start to rain down.
其中一个人是个家伙，正如你在陈述中所说，蒂利乌斯·辛布尔，他带着一份请愿书走近，然后他抓住了凯撒的托加长袍。接着一个叫卡斯卡的家伙似乎从他的喉咙下方刺了他一刀。打击雨点般落了下来。
Yeah. And according to Suetonius, who gives our best account, there were 23 wounds of which, according to the doctor who then subsequently did the postmortem on him, only one had been fatal. And we get the detail from Plutarch that every conspirator had agreed to stab Caesar once, which, you know, squaring those two accounts implies that there were 23 conspirators. But I think that's, you know, I think that's putting too much weight. It's very murder on the Orient Express, isn't it? Yes, it is. It is. But they all have to kind of dip their hands in the blood. Yes. And in your account, you said, you know, Caesar runs, that he cries out. There are actually,
是的。根据给我们最好记录的苏托尼乌斯的说法，有23处伤口，根据后来对他的尸体进行尸检的医生的说法，其中只有一处是致命的。我们从普鲁塔克那里得到的细节是，每个密谋者都同意刺凯撒一次，你知道，把这两个记录结合起来意味着有23个密谋者。但我认为这，你知道，我认为这是给它加了太多的分量。这非常像《东方快车谋杀案》，不是吗？是的，确实如此。确实如此。但他们都必须把手浸在血里。是的。在你的描述中，你说，你知道，凯撒跑了，他大喊大叫。实际上，
we don't really know. The confusion of the event means that we have kind of various accounts of what happens. So Suetonius says that, you know, he's read accounts in which Caesar lay silent under the rain of blows. Plutarch says that Caesar fought back until he sees Brutus come. So there are various accounts. Caesar's last words, the et tu Brute is in Shakespeare. Shakespeare invents that. Yes, of course. And you Brutus. Yes. His last words, two of our sources, one of whom is Suetonius, they say that in Greek, he says, you too, my boy, my son, looking at Brutus.
我们并不是很清楚。事件的混乱意味着我们有关于发生事情的各种记录。所以苏托尼乌斯说，你知道，他读过关于凯撒在刀光剑影中默默倒下的记录。普鲁塔克说凯撒进行了反击，直到他看到布鲁图斯来。所以有各种各样的记录。凯撒的遗言，莎士比亚剧中的“你也是吗，布鲁图斯？”莎士比亚发明了那个。是的，当然。你也是，布鲁图斯。是的。他的遗言，我们的两个消息来源，其中一个是苏托尼乌斯，他们说他在希腊语中说：“你也是，我的孩子，我的儿子”，看着布鲁图斯。
But which Brutus? Marcus junius or decimus marcus junius brutus but it's possible i mean you know it's possible in in all the confusion i mean the scene must have been so chaotic and confused that any attempt to impose order on the sources must be a fool's errand because who i mean they probably would have given you different accounts themselves the conspirators yeah yeah and caesar dies he he pulls his toga over his head so that people won't be able to see his face in death blood spills out and laps the base of a statue of pompey the great everybody flees the senators who are not in the conspiracy in a state of mass panic. According to some accounts, there are some who are trampled to death in the chaos. The conspirators who call themselves liberators hold their daggers aloft. Brutus calls out Cicero's name, kind of saying, implying that Cicero had been a great inspiration for this. And they charge out expecting to be greeted as liberators. Caesar's body lies there. And Suetonius gives us the account, the chamber then emptied and his lifeless body lay there a while
但那是哪个布鲁图斯？马库斯·容尼斯还是德西穆斯？马库斯·容尼斯·布鲁图斯。但这可能是真的，我的意思是，你知道，在所有的混乱中，这完全是可能的，我的意思是，当时的场景一定如此混乱，以至于任何试图理清史料的做法都注定是徒劳的，因为究竟是谁——密谋者自己当时可能也会给出不同的说法。是的，是的。凯撒死了。他把托加长袍拉过头顶，这样人们在死时就看不到他的脸了。鲜血涌出，流淌在大庞培雕像的基座上。所有人都在恐慌中逃跑，不是密谋者的元老院成员陷入了大规模的恐慌。根据一些记录，有些人甚至在混乱中被踩踏致死。自称为解放者的密谋者高举匕首。布鲁图斯大声喊出西塞罗的名字，似乎在暗示西塞罗是这一切的巨大灵感来源。他们冲了出去，期待着被当作解放者欢迎。凯撒的尸体躺在那里。苏托尼乌斯为我们记录了当时的场景：房间随后空了，他的无生命躯体在那里躺了一会儿，
until three young slaves bundled it into a litter and carried it home, one arm dangling as it went. Crikey. What an amazingly colourful and resonant detail that is. Tom, a brilliant narrative.
直到三个年轻的奴隶把它塞进一辆轿子里并抬回家，一只手臂在途中垂落着。天哪。这是一个多么惊人、多彩且意味深长的细节啊。汤姆，叙事太精彩了。
And the great thing is, it's not over is it no because um listeners to the rest is history club can find out immediately what happens next what you know are the liberators greeted with open arms what's going to happen to mark anthony some of you i suspect will know the answers to these questions but you haven't heard it told by the inimitable tom holland as you will be able to if you're a member of the Restless History Club. If you're not, you'll have to wait till Thursday, which is, I mean, no great hardship, but why suffer at all, Tom? Why not just listen to it now?
最棒的是，事情还没结束，不是吗？不，因为……“历史即全部”俱乐部的听众可以立即知道接下来发生了什么，你知道，解放者是受到热烈欢迎吗，马克·安东尼会怎么样？我猜你们中的一些人会知道这些答案，但你们没有听过由无与伦比的汤姆·霍兰所讲述的这一切，就像如果你是“历史即全部”俱乐部的会员就能听到的一样。如果你不是，你将不得不等到星期四，我的意思是，这倒也不是什么大罪，但汤姆，为什么要受这种折磨呢？为什么不现在就听呢？
Absolutely. Pile in. Right. On that bombshell, we will say goodbye and we will see you next time. Goodbye. Bye-bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment.
绝对的。快加入吧。好了。伴随着这个重磅消息，我们要说再见了，我们下期见。再见。再见。感谢收听《历史即全部》。如需收听番外节目、抢先体验、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。网址是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐即全部》。
It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad ad-free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to the There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论和一点八卦绯闻。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想收听无广告节目、独家番外并优先购买现场门票，请访问... 本集节目尚无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。